Val Chmerkovskiy dishes on his fuller  house kids it was awesome the dancing  with the stars pro will appear on an  upcoming episode of fuller house with  his brother Max PT was with Val on  Monday and he dished on his new role I  think full the house is an amazing  concept the show was so much fun and  work on my first sitcom I love to Trent  you know I'd love to transition into  acting as a passion of mine and you know  to have been able to do my brother and  my friend can this is on the show jodie  sweetin was awesome it was a dream come  true I grew up honestly I grew up  watching full house and for me it was a  bucket list thing to check off the  brothers will reportedly play DJ and  Stephanie's love interests so we had to  know just how sexy did it get we got a  call back we got a call back I'll just  say that we got a call back have mercy